スマナサーラ師匠ありがとうございました
だいぶ時間が押しておりますが
皆さんお疲れだとは思いますが
質問などある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手していただけます
お釈迦様が菩提樹のところで悟り開かれた後
7週間にわたって行かいながらいらっしゃったということなんですが
その時何をなさっていたのかというと
7週目に 梵天が 梵天が説法をしてくださいと頼まれ
頼みに来たので説法を始めるかという話があるのですが
先ほどのお話ですと もう人々のためにやっているんだから
説法するのは当然の話だと
そこのこの違い  はい えーと
この 7週間はお釈迦様のもう 45 年間の
伝道活動の準備時間だと私は思いますね
あの あの 7週間で この真理はどのように語るのかというね
準備時間ですよ だから
何を行ったかということは記録がありますから
1週間そのまま禅定に入ったままでいて
2週間目は菩提樹のところに悟ったんだから
立って禅定に入って立ったままでいて
それから 3週間目は立ったところと座った間で勤偏していて
インドに行ったら全部その場所がありますからね
それから 3週間目では
このちょっと今ボディがあるところに裏側仏塔があって
そこで座って仏教の理論論理は何なのか
真理は何なのかとずっと観察して
いわゆるもうすごいことを発見したんだから
言葉さえないんです この真理語る言葉一つもないんだから
だからどう語ればいいかということはね
大変ですよ それからこの偉大なる出来事を雨が降りましたからね
1週間も そこでなんかね
コブラのお世話になっていて
まあそういうそういう順番がありますね
何か何かやったっていう
そういうのはもう仏典でそういうふうに記録してあって
インドに行ってもそういう場所全部あるんだから
仏教は別に嘘を言う必要はないんだからね
そうかもしれませんし
我々現代人の考え方を見れば
この巨大な教えを教えるために
7週間で準備期間というのは想像できないんですよ
普通はみんなもう 5 6
年  7 8年 10年研究して博士論文をやって出しますから
博士論文といえばもう 1万冊も乗り越えるぐらいの仏典でしょ
これが 7週間の準備で語ったんですね
それでもお釈迦様が やっぱりこれは人間には語れないものであると
人間の持ちの程度を考えたらね
語れないものであると疲れるんだ
だから語る気持ちがあったんです
あったんだけど 誰もわかってくれませんだからまあ意味がないな
語ってもという この ちょっとその気持ちになったところで
梵天から来てこんなことを思ったら困りますよと
それぐらいのことで困りますよ
人間はもう不幸で陥って地獄に落ちる羽目になるんだよと
輪廻脱出できないでしょうにと
だからみんなわからないのは当たり前
我々も同じ気持ちですよ
私たちはどれほど力いっぱい喋っても
まあ一人二人も理解するかどうかわかりませんよ
だからといって別に力抜いたりすることはしませんよ
私はもう時間延ばして喋ってますけど
同じ力なんです だからもうお釈迦様のご指導ありますからね
人は理解しようかしないかどうかはそれとも関係もなく
やっぱりもし万が一誰かが理解したら
その人は幸福になりますからね
それは無駄にしないということで説法するんだ
だから梵天に行ったのはそういうことなんです
もしかすると あの梵天の神様がお釈迦様ではなくて
我々説法する人々に行った可能性もありますよ
あなた方はね 調子に乗るんじゃないんだよと
世の中では謙虚で頑張ってみなさいよという言葉かもしれません
だからお釈迦様がまあ話す気持ちはあったんですよ
だから自分が道を発見しなくちゃいけないし
自分がそれを教えなくちゃいけない
それはもう責任逃れではなくて
どうやればということなんですね
もう今方法を持ってます
教えも全部整理整頓しています
それでもこれは大変なおっかない仕事やと言ったら
いえ わかる人もいるんだと言ったら
お釈迦様はなるほど わかる人ならお釈迦様見つかったのはたった一人なんですよ
まず自分に教えてくれた最初にね
アーラーラカーラーナ仙人でウッダカラーム仙人
あの人ならもう瞑想達人だからわかるでしょうと見たら
１週間まで亡くなってる
あ それだったらブッダから仙人がいいんじゃないかなと
あの人に能力あるんだと
どこにいたら自分の超能力見たら前の日亡くなられているんですと
大変な損失もあったと
あの二人がお釈迦様にね
瞑想をちょこちょこと教えてくれたんだから
すごい感謝の気持ちあるんですね
まあしょうがない いつでもそばにいた家来の五人に
教えるぞということで教えが教え始めたんですね
だから７週間でね いろいろ準備なさったんじゃないかなと
それは全部心の中のことだからね
思います はい